[Music]
spider-man no way home stunt coordinator
george cuttle's post caused great buzz
among the fan community recently
after the filming was completed cuddle
thanked a large number of people from
the team including tom holland and
zendaya
so far nothing out of the ordinary
notable was however the mention of stunt
performer chris daniels
who already assisted dobie maguire in
samrami's spider-man trilogy
in connection with the fact that andrew
garfield stuntman william spencer
recently published pictures of his
collaboration with tomorrow and stuntman
craig tonley
it seems very likely that the three
spider-man will be appearing in the same
film
additionally last monday it came to
light that roger pereira the spanish
voice actor of tobey maguire is
already working on spider-man in the way
home can't have a lot of hints about the
trio
but officially marvel and sony are still
staying out of fan speculations
spider-man no way home will be released
on december 17
2021 the upcoming video game adaption
borderlands has already been filmed
yet lionsgate didn't miss the
opportunity to announce a new addition
to the cast
we're talking about the venezuelan actor
edgar ramirez who will play the
businessman
and weapons producer atlas gearbox boss
randy pitchfork shared more than just
that with fans via twitter as the 49
year old also had some information on
the universe in which the film will take
place
there will be clear separation between
the borderlands movie universe and the
borland's video game universe the
characters and the style of the film
will be similar but at the same time
they will focus on new storylines and
new tales that have not been told before
meaning that the game of the movie will
offer two completely different contents
in addition to the recently cast ramirez
the movie's cast also include kate
blanchet as lilith kevin hart as roland
jamie lee curtis as tanis jack black as
claptrap florian monteneux creek ariana
greenblatt as tiny tina
and haley bennett in a still undisclosed
role as synopsis has also been
officially revealed so for example lift
will have to face her past and return to
her home planet pandora
there she will form an alliance with
various companions to find the missing
daughter of the mighty atlas
they will all have to fight against
alien creatures and ruthless
bandits as the girl could be the key to
unimaginable power
unfortunately a release date for the
borderlands film has not yet been
specified
the story of creed around sylvester
stallone is rocky balboa and michael b
jordan as adonis johnson in 2015 not
only thrilled boxing fans around the
globe in both films released so far
rocky actor stallone played a major role
as the protagonist trainer and mentor
but apparently that's going to change in
the upcoming third part
as stallone confirmed in an instagram
post he will no longer be
involved in creed iii therefore michael
b jordan's role of adonis johnson will
seemingly get more emphasis in the
storyline of the film as confirmed by
stallone
those who still want to see more of
rocky balboa can look forward to an
upcoming prequel series to the rocky
saga however the 74 year old stallone
will not be playing the lead role
as the planned protagonist of the series
is only 17 years old
we are eagerly awaiting the upcoming
creed 3 which will also be michael b
jordan's directing debut the release
date is expected to be in november
2022 after
several shooting breaks and unfortunate
injuries to lead actor henry cavill the
witcher team was happy to announce the
completion of shooting to fans
in a video showrunner lauren s his ridge
expresses her gratitude to the more than
1200 people
involved in the production and recaps
the 158 long days of filming for season
2.
a total of 89 actors worked in front of
the camera and paid meticulous
attention to hygienic measures behind
the camera fans will however be most
pleased with another piece of news since
the witcher season 2 will be released
this year there is no precise date yet
but we strongly expect to be released at
the end of the year
what do you anticipate from the second
season and do you think the team will
manage to tie in with a great first
season
feel free to write us in the comments
some time ago paramount pictures put its
blockbuster
the tomorrow war up for sale to the big
streaming providers as deadline reported
several were interested in the action
spectacle with chris pratt in the lead
role but as is now known since wednesday
the big player amazon has obtained their
international rights in return the
provider has invested quite a bit of
money because it is set the right cost a
whopping 200 million us dollars in the
end so it seems that amazon has high
hopes for the blockbuster which was
originally supposed to be released at
the end of 2020.
just like coming to america or without
remorse to name but a few the tomorrow
war belongs to a series of movies that
were actually intended for theaters but
could not be released in the planned
time frame
the content of the film which is
produced by the director of lego batman
is about the main character played by
chris pratt who is in an intergalactic
war against aliens together with many
other humans in the course of this
clever scientists come up with the idea
of sending soldiers from the past
back to the battlefield of the present
the international release date for the
tomorrow war is july 2nd
2021 on amazon prime
some days ago actress terrorists spoke
about a possible sequel to the american
pie series in an interview
allegedly a script already exists that
she herself considers to be great
she also confirmed that american pie
will definitely come
she just doesn't know when the american
pie franchise has existed since 1999 and
includes a total of four films to date
the last of which titled american pie
presents girls rules
was released last year let's just hope
that the new movie won't be as bad as
girls rules
a release date is not known yet sadly
but we will of course keep you up to
date on our website and in our weekly
[Music]
news
[Music]
you